yeah are you drinking your [ __ ]
because I'm not Auburn I'm not a tart
heart and ass you are at you're a [ __ ]
sweet tart tart NASA no I'm not welcome
to the Super Deluxe okayed and the sweet
tart not NASA now what's going on with
you oh dude no hey dude Brian tries to
take it down to a boring ville [ __ ]
what do you want to talk about bro we're
here this is it yeah [ __ ] Brendan
Schaub he's not here huh no he's not guy
doesn't eat honestly doesn't eat you
know what he doesn't have he doesn't
have the [ __ ] determination that's
why he's not how I feel yeah I'll tell
you something else he's off in Austin
he's working on other business matters
that's right he's being mr. entrepreneur
yeah I don't have that in me
I'm not a beautiful former bro I'm a
performer yep he's got all kinds of
ventures I know he's gonna be like very
wealthy yeah god bless him I go like
this I go oh cool that's good thank you
guys let's talk about big brown coffee
I'm like all right I'm surprised you
showed up here before I did to be honest
no I've been on time later yeah know if
you had a sound effect for who you are
and what your life is what would it be
don't be a dick okay won't be honest
like I won't crystally is life give me a
sound effect don't be okay just be
honest you want to hear it is it no it's
not that all right I don't know you know
what it is it's this and that's obvious
oh that's a rocket taking off yep and
then turning into [ __ ] sparkly flames
yep really yeah and I'm right I'm
stumped if you can believe it or not I'm
still at the launching sequence really
right now cuz I've what so I was trying
for me I guess because you really oh
right but right but yours will be oh no
no I I'm not to be a dick I think mine
because I'm older and I've kind of
gotten to where it's like I I'm so Oh
in a way cuz I've ever well no I've I've
broken through that so so you're still
trying to find it and in a way when you
reach that you go I've been here this
whole time you know that it comes full
circle yeah it does well I don't [ __ ]
believe a word you say but that's how
about that how often you YouTube my
stand up to inspire you do you have
clips on YouTube and besides this
[ __ ] show do you have time for do
you have clip yeah I stay up on ya do ya
I do you know the Kevin Hart after I did
ride along called me up and he goes hey
man I'm just calling I'm wondering why
why do you only have like like 170 view
thousand he's talking about is you don't
know him I do huh I know Kevin Hart dude
we did the [ __ ] Justin Bieber roast
and I saw him a few months ago at the
Comedy Store and he brought me up on
stage well I have to read bumped me nah
but not for long why would I give that
to you as it's a gift it's a gift it's a
gift